jedes jahr einmal nimmt die queen den
weg vom palast über die römer zum
parlament so auch im mai 2021 ihr
königreich ist in einer zerreißprobe
128000 briten sind an cholera gestorben
die delta variante droht die erfolge der
impfkampagne zu zerstören immer noch ist
das land tief zerstritten über den dreck
zieht dessen folgen erst langsam
deutlich werden da ist die queen der
fels in der brandung mehr denn je die
95-jährige tröstet mahnt mundart auf und
verließ das regierungsprogramm
meine regierung wird die demokratie und
die verfassung stärken und erneuern
meine minister werden die stärke und den
zusammenhalt der union vorantreiben
die union stärken das reich
zusammenhalten
es ist der vornehmste auftrag der queen
eine aufgabe der sie ihr ganzes leben
gewidmet hat und die zu scheitern droht
der palast mitten in london mitten in
der hauptstadt im herzen englands
doch vier herzen schlagen im königreich
wir sind ihnen alle vier nationen
gereist um herauszufinden wie es steht
um die einheit des landes welche kräfte
an dem alten konstrukts herrn das reich
der kliniken sie lange überleben wird
es ist das spiel der spiele
die älteste begegnung im internationalen
fußball
schottland gegen england sind halt die
alten nachbarn sie haben uns unterdrückt
sie haben uns geschlagen wie haben sie
geschlagen
es ist alte rivalität unter nachbarn
1872 haben engländer und schotten das
erste mal gegeneinander gespielt bei der
europameisterschaft 20 21 stehen sie
sich im wembley-stadion gegenüber trotz
corona sind tausende schotten nach
london gereist es ist eine gigantische
rivalität nicht nur im fußball auch in
der politik es wird immer politischer
immer mehr schotten wollen die
unabhängigkeit
seit dem vollzug des brh exit ist es das
erste spiel gegen den alten feind
england den glasgow schottlands größter
stadt sind sie auf der fanmeile schon
völlig außer rand und band
[Musik]
wir mögen die nicht das bedeutet mehr
als alles andere denn die leidenschaft
beim schottland gegen england ist
einfach größer
das kann man gar nicht messen wir sind
einfach leidenschaftlicher wir wollen
nicht gewinnen
das lud zu 0 im gruppenspiel feiern sie
dann
als wären sie die weltmeister empfing
der wende war die engländer denken sie
sind wunderbar schottland ist natürlich
der underdog aber hey leidenschaft page
in schottland dreht sich alles um
leidenschaft
[Musik]
[Applaus]
viel party ist momentan nicht in
schottland die korona regeln sind noch
strikter als in england ständig spielt
im theater von lief in einen burger ganz
ohne publikum
eine typisch schottische band auch weil
sie ganz selbstverständlich eine
norweger und einen deutschen zählt und
sich mit politischen ansichten nicht
zurück wie die meisten jungen schotten
sind die musiker für die unabhängigkeit
dafür sich frei zu machen von einem so
viel größeren nachbarn der die fünf
millionen schotten immer wieder
überstimmt
so geht es auch rebecca und thilo in
england wird traditionell rechts gewählt
während schottland immer links welt und
es ist egal wie die schotten abstimmen
weil die bevölkerung so klein ist
es war so frustrierend zu sehen dass wir
in der eu bleiben wollten und dann gehen
mussten weil die engländer es so wollten
kilo ist schon sein halbes leben in
schottland er spricht inzwischen lieber
englisch als deutsch
es ist lustig denn als ich hierherkam
kam ich natürlich mit dieser
europäischen idee dass man
zusammenarbeiten
es hat bei mir etwa zehn jahre gedauert
bis ich kapiert habe dass die schotten
keinen fairen deal bekommen mehr wollen
sie gar nicht lasst die schotten ihre
eigenen fehler machen dann können sie
auch nicola station schimpfen und nicht
mehr auf boris johnson johnson
repräsentiert schottland nicht
hier mag ihn eigentlich niemand die
korona krise bot nicolas deutschen die
gelegenheit sich einmal mehr von boris
johnson abzugrenzen die
gesundheitspolitik wird in den
regionalparlamenten entschieden die
erste ministerin schottlands profilierte
sich mit strikteren und konsequenteren
maßnahmen deutschen hat eine tägliche
pressekonferenz abgehalten die ich immer
gut fand sie war transparent und ehrlich
im vergleich zu dem was wir aus dem
süden sei für sie einfach irgendwelche
sachen erfunden und ihren kumpels
verträge verschafft haben es schien als
würde dort viel gelogen und hier schien
es ehrlicher es hat den abstand zwischen
uns nochmal vergrößern
wenn thilo nicht mit standing spielt
macht er musik mit vernachlässigten
jugendlichen ende mai hatten er und die
kids hohen besuch
thilo führte die herzogin von cambridge
ins lupen 1
die älteren fanden sie sagt und da also
ja ich hatte einen jüngeren deren
reserven also kaum reserven ist dem es
also wie gesagt habe ja kommt ist also
da hat ja auch maske an dass wir seinen
augen gesehen aber mein gott und der der
vergleich zu seiner mutter getrennt als
er sie dann weg waren und man hat alles
erzählt er war schon ein erlebnis für
ihn auf jeden fall aber direkten
einfluss auf weiteres leben also nicht
ob das hat die meisten kids heutzutage
kümmern sich recht wenig trotzdem hat
der palast seine königskinder
losgeschickt kate und william sind fast
eine woche lang auf charmeoffensive in
hollywood panels laden sie mitarbeiter
des gesundheitsdienstes zu einem
autokino abend ein danken ihnen für den
einsatz bei corona der rest von
edinburgh nimmt kaum notiz
[Musik]
das ist mir völlig egal mehr kann ich
nicht sagen ich möchte dass schottland
bleibt ich glaube wir würden einfach
nicht überleben allein
[Musik]
es sieht aus als würden sie sich mehr
anstrengen sie wollen dass das land
zusammen bleibt und dieser besuch zeigt
dass sie nicht nur für england da sind
sondern für alle
die schotten hatten fiel auf ihren sinn
für die gemeinschaft auf mehr
solidarität untereinander offenheit
gegenüber fremden ihre skepsis gegenüber
der obrigkeit
es ist doch empörend dass zwei leute ihr
hoch kommen jede menge ressourcen von
rauchen platz beanspruchen zeit und dass
das dann die union stärken soll
mehr als wenn es politische gespräche
oder diskussionen zwischen menschen in
den nationen gibt um ihre eigenheiten
besser ausleben zu können bekamen
nordirland wales und schottland 1998
eigene parlamente zur eröffnung des
gebäudes in allen burger kam die queen
und gab ihm ihren segen
die hoffnung war dass die schotten sich
so mit ihrer rolle in der junioren
besser abfinden würden doch der
widerstandsgeist hat seitdem eine neue
bühne
im mai wird der abgeordnete angus
robertson eingeschworen er macht ein
statement daraus ich eingeschlossen
gelobe feierlich aufrichtig und
wahrhaftig loyal zu sein und ihre
majestät königin elizabeth ihren erden
und nachfolgend gewissenhaft die treue
zu halten
selbst einem eingeschworenen
schottischen nationalisten geht dieser
satz leicht über die lippen schließlich
könnte die queen auch in einem
unabhängigen schottland staatsoberhaupt
sein
also meine mutter stammt aus deutschland
und ich bin europäer also es passt zu
meiner identität und es passt zu unserer
demokratie in schottland dass man
angelobt werden kann in verschiedenen
sprachen
william und kate sind ganz klar auf
mission schon beim ersten referendum
2014 hatte die queen ganz gegen ihren
auftrag erkennen lassen dass sie die
unabhängigkeit für einen fehler hätte
dass die königliche familie wieder aktiv
versucht die schotten vom wert des
verbundes mit england zu überzeugen will
angus robertson nicht hören
die queen dürfe sich gar nicht in die
politik einmischen
die königin hat keine politische
meinungen ich würde es für undenkbar und
unwahrscheinlich halten dass die
königliche familie sich in der politik
einmischen würde sie betonen dass sie
das nicht machen und die
verfassungsexperten unterstreichen wie
wichtig ist es ist dass sie das nicht
machen weil wenn wir eine politische
monarchie haben dann ist das dann gleich
dass wir mit einer republik aber ohne
wahlen und das wäre das wäre auch
undenkbar
wenn schottland welt dann gibt es seit
14 jahren der schottischen
nationalpartei die macht offensiv
einwanderungs freundlich tolerant und
links liberal ist die snp so ganz anders
als andere parteien die sich national
nennen
gelb ist die farbe der partei und gelb
trug nicolas deutschen als sie im mai
2021 die regionalwahlen gewann mit aller
kraft fordert sie ein zweites referendum
nach dem knapp verlorenen von 2014
drechsel und corona haben denen die die
schottische flagge zu einer staatsflagge
machen wollen neuen mut gegeben in den
umfragen lagen sie monatelang vorn
noch weigert sich london einem
referendum zuzustimmen
doch das robertson ist sich da ganz
sicher mit boris johnson nicht
durchhalten
was könnte jetzt den fortbestand des
königreichs noch retten ist unrettbar in
meiner ansicht dass ist mit einem
föderalen echten fehler ein
bitte nennen mir einen förderation
überhaupt in der geschichte wo 85
prozent der einwohner in einem teil des
feldes der föderation leben
es ist unmöglich für eine ferne deutsche
audienz monate stehen wir sind kein ich
will niemandem verunglimpfen aber wir
sind kein schleswig holstein oder
sachsen anhalt oder bayern
schottland ist eine einer nation wir
waren es immer wir sind es jetzt wir
sind eine nation ohne staat zu sein aber
wir werden bald auch wer einen start
sein
ein start zwei drei oder vier das
königreich droht in viele kleine zu
zerfallen vier kleine königreiche nicht
nur in den augen der queen wäre das
nicht mehr sondern sehr viel weniger
auf den mauern des cardiff castle der
burg im herzen der hauptstadt von wales
venen jede menge walisische flaggen die
rot weiß grünen mit dem drachen und fast
verschämt ein britischer union jack
[Musik]
stolz auf ihr land waren die walliser
schon immer und auf ihre eigene sprache
[Musik]
die berühmten männerchöre von hier
singen gerne auf walisisch denkmalsockel
und straßenschilder sind zweisprachig
die letzten jahre haben die politische
landschaft stark verändert welt strebt
nach mehr eigenständigkeit ein drittel
ist mittlerweile für die loslösung vom
vereinigten königreich in ihrem podcast
us- jetzt versuchen männern evans und
craig kane festzuhalten wie sich die
stimmung allmählich dreht sie reisen
durchs land um meinungen zur
unabhängigkeit einzufangen
klar können wir es alleine schaffen wir
haben genug erneuerbare energien und die
wirtschaft ist stark genug
warum also nicht ich sehe wirklich nicht
was das bringen soll
wenn man bedenkt wie viel finanzielle
unterstützung wales von der britischen
regierung bekommt natürlich das vorteile
vor allem wenn man sieht wie die
regierung in westminster
die walisische regierung einfach
übergeht aber es bleiben viele ungelöste
fragen was machen wir mit der grenze
oder mit der währung diesen herren
müssen die beiden erst gar nicht fragen
er ist ein fan ihres podcast und was er
von der unabhängigkeit hält das jahr zu
wales trägt er auf seinem mundschutz
auftrieb erhalten meinen männern und
greg habe die walisische
unabhängigkeitsbewegung vor allem
aufgrund der jüngsten politischen
turbulenzen im königreich wechselt ist
sehr stark vom englischen nationalismus
befeuert wurde so hat es sich für mich
zumindest angesichts ideologie und vom
rechten rand gegen einwanderung und so
bin ich überhaupt erst auf die
unabhängigkeitsbewegung aufmerksam
geworden weil ich erkannte dass man das
alles besser machen kann
weg von der negativität und der
vergifteten atmosphäre die der praxis
geschaffen
wir wollen ein weltoffenes land sein
aber das wird uns nicht gelingen so
lange wir im vereinigten königreich sind
denn das bewegt sich in die falsche
richtung
und wie halten die beiden es mit dem
königshaus eine menge leute mögen basis
für prinz william prinz charles ist
nicht so groß glaube ich wenn die queen
nicht mehr königin ist wird sich daher
vielleicht einiges ändern denn die leute
wollen die queen die haben gute pr für
die queen gemacht für prinz charles gilt
das weniger dass der thronfolge der
britischen monarchie den titel prince of
wales trägt ist dafür viele walliser
weniger trost denn provokation als
königin elizabeth die zweite 1969 ihren
sohn charles diese krone aufsetzte
verfolgten dies 4000 geladene gäste auf
der burg kindern im nordwesten des
landes und millionen zuschauer weltweit
einen bildschirm
das zeremoniell war mehr royale show und
pr als eine notwendigkeit charles trug
seinen titel da nämlich schon seit elf
jahren den ersten prince of wales gab es
1301 nachdem die engländer wales erobert
und den letzten walisischen herrscher
hingerichtet hatten nicht nur die
schotten schleppen so manchen
historischen groll gegen die engländer
mit sich herum und ähnlich wie in
schottland hat auch in wales die korona
krise den wunsch nach selbstständigkeit
befördert das kleine land im westen der
insel betrieb seine eigene corona
politik mitunter erfolgreicher als der
große nachbar england und schreckte
dabei nicht davor zurück auch engländern
die einreise zu verbieten
zum lohn wurde der erste minister mark
drake wird von der labour partei bei den
wahlen zum set dem walisischen parlament
nach stimmen zu gewinnen im amt
bestätigt erleichtert und bereit weiter
zu arbeiten
anders als england wählte wales
überwiegend links der mitte und jeder
fünfte stimmte für die walisischen
nationalisten
marc huber hat sich der unabhängigkeit
verschrieben er will ihr struktur geben
mit einer der ältesten institutionen der
welt einer bank das rein walisische
geldinstitut bank kamiya soll bereits ab
anfang nächsten jahres seine türen
öffnen mit zweieinhalb millionen konten
würden in wales jedes jahr über eine
milliarde pfund umsatz erzielt rechnet
marc huber vor das geld aber mit den
internationalen großbanken die region
verlassen
man kann hier ist eine genossenschaft
wird lokale projekte fördern und
walisisches geld in wales lassen ein
wichtiger schritt zur unabhängigkeit und
loslösung vom großen nachbarn england
meint huber das timing spielt hier eine
große rolle
viele leute haben begonnen alte
beziehungen zu hinterfragen das
verhältnis zu einer bank ist meistens
ein lang andauerndes menschen lassen
sich scheiden als dass sie ihre bank
wechseln
und da kommt co wird ins spiel
unterbrechen
die walisische gesellschaft ist an dem
punkt angelangt alte beziehungen in
frage zu stellen wie nötig eine
walisische bank ist will mag uns im
kleinen örtchen im südwesten des landes
zeigen drei banken und zwei
bausparkassen hat es hier einmal gegeben
nun hat auch das letzte kreditinstitute
dichtgemacht
die bürgermeisterin und mitglieder des
gemeinderats können es kaum erwarten die
bank cambria hier zu begrüßen
zusätzlich wohltuend wäre das fürs
walisische selbstverständnis dass er nur
zu wahlen durch das feuchte wetter
getrübt werden kann
wir sind sehr stolz auf unsere herkunft
stolz darauf war lisa zu sein
eine walisische bank zu haben wäre
wundervoll und ich bin mir sicher dass
jeder ein acer auch angehen würde
genau so sehen das auch die
geschäftsleute im ort eine walisische
bank würde gut passen in eine umgebung
in der es keine ladenketten filialen
gibt und der einzelhandel seinen namen
noch verdient man setzt auf lokale
produkte ob im kleiderladen oder in der
metzgerei
lammfleisch aus wales hat den
allerbesten ruf über die landesgrenzen
hinaus
[Musik]
das liegt wahrscheinlich an dem saftigen
grün auf den fairways typischen hügel
farmen und zehn millionen schafe weiden
auf walisisch diesen als im juni 2016
die walliser mit knapper mehrheit für
den austritt aus der eu stimmten waren
schafbauern nur in den seltensten fällen
dafür vor dem wechsel ging fast die
hälfte allen walisischen lammfleisch in
den export und davon über 90 prozent in
die eu
damals befürchtete ihnen bringt man das
schlimmste exportzölle auf sein land
fleisch das immerhin konnte das an
weihnachten letzten jahres geschlossene
dragset abkommen mit der eu gerade noch
verhindern
hygiene kontrollen und ein mehr an
bürokratie verursachen ihm jedoch
zusätzliche kosten ein silberstreif in
der korona krise haben die briten mehr
lammfleisch gegessen das hat ihn bisher
vor größeren einkommenseinbußen bewahrt
es ist schwer zu sagen was mehr
auswirkungen auf den sektor hatte corona
oder das hat sich alles vermischt was
uns natürlich auch sorge bereitet ist
die frage wie es mit den subventionen
kann ohne subventionen nicht überleben
es herrscht große verunsicherung
wir haben die sicherheit die
kuscheldecke der eu-agrarpolitik
verlassen
jetzt sind wir hier draußen in der
schönen neuen welt
die frage ob darin die hohen standards
den sich die britische landwirtschaft
verschrieben hat gehalten werden können
bereitet ihm sorge im postbereich
szenario versucht die regierung
handelsverträge mit ländern zu schließen
die nicht so viel auf artgerechte
haltung der tiere den minimalen einsatz
von medikamenten und umweltschutz geben
wie walisische schafbauern wenn die
australier für ihre lamm und rindfleisch
und eingeschränkten zugang zu unseren
markt bekommen haben wir ein problem
ohne zelle und tarife besteht die gefahr
dass sie uns unterbieten und den markt
mit ihren billigeren produkten
überflutet
und wie soll das erst werden wenn london
handels einigkeit mit den usa anstrebt
sagt ihn seine glücklichen schafe
könnten da schlicht nicht mehr mithalten
[Musik]
auf einem hof rund 80 kilometer von uns
entfernt zelebriert der cau bridge
männerchor etwas das in wales ähnlich
große tradition hat wie die schafzucht
die herren haben ihren ersten auftritt
in diesem jahr aufgrund von corinna
regeln in einer luftigen scheune
die zuschauer live online
gesungen wird auf walisisch nicht nur
aber eben auch welt hat seine ganz
eigene kultur und beruft sich immer
stärker darauf
[Musik]
auch das kleine wales lange ein wenig
belächelt und oft vernachlässigt fühlte
sich nie fremder im königreich als
gerade jetzt
[Musik]
nordirland im sonnenschein traum schön
die küsten der vierte nation des
vereinigten königreichs
von großbritannien getrennt durch die
irische see
an ihrer schmalsten stelle so einer der
großen pläne von boris johnson soll eine
brücke die beiden teile des königreichs
miteinander verbinden
irgendwann vielleicht jetzt erstmal bei
exit chaos weil es aufgrund der immer
noch angespannten lage in nordirland
keine grenze zwischen der republik und
im norden geben darf hat dass nordirland
protokoll des brh exit die grenze auf
die irische see verschoben
waren die aus großbritannien zum hafen
entlang kommen und von dort weiter nach
irland also in den europäischen
binnenmarkt gelangen könnten müssen nun
hier kontrolliert werden wir brauchen
jetzt sogar formular um in die andere
richtung zu fahren formulare für beide
richtungen ab juni ein alptraum
die britische regierung hat uns
reingelegt
das seitdem rexit alles mühsamer und
teurer geworden ist beklagen fast alle
nordirischen unternehmer dabei hatte
sich das land in den letzten jahren
gerade erst erholt vom jahrzehntelangen
bürgerkrieg die highstreet in belfast
endet endlich einer in england nun aber
fühlen sie sich wieder zurückgeworfen
diesen kleinen feinen lebensmittelladen
diese sind auf fast seit 80 jahren
besitzer mark brown hat plötzlich ganz
neue sorgen meine hauptsorge ist oktober
oder wann immer das nordirland protokoll
des praxis wirklich in den fokus rückt
dann kommen hier so sachen wie weizen
mutter nicht mehr nach nordirland waren
und ohne die keine crack ich werde ein
echtes problem haben an weihnachten dirk
recker zu bekommen für den käse braun
importiert seinem mediterranen produkte
aus der eu ein drittel aus
großbritannien den rest aus irland aus
angst dass sie waren zu spät oder gar
nicht mehr ankommen kaufte er mehr und
mehr in irland ein kleines beispiel
dafür wie zwischen großbritannien
nordirland und dem süden alles in
bewegung ist
das problem mit nordirland ist dass wir
mit instabilität nicht gut umgehen gibt
es wichtigen leuten den anlass ärger zu
machen momentan sorge ich mich darum
nicht so sehr aber mittel und
langfristig wer weiß mit dem tempo als
im april fahrzeuge brennen in belfast
und terry fühlen sich viele an den
bürgerkrieg erinnert protestantische
jugendliche greifen ihre katholischen
nachbarn und die polizei an ausdruck von
wut über das nordirland protokoll des
brh exit abkommens die de facto
seegrenze so fürchten sie führe über
kurz oder lang zu einer abtrennung vom
mutterland zu einem vereinten irland in
dem sie nichts mehr zu sagen haben
es ist nur eine kleine minderheit die
wirklich wieder treffe also ärger macht
troubles sowie die zeit des bürgerkriegs
in nordirland heißt als protestantische
loyalisten und katholische republikaner
gegeneinander kämpften 3500 menschen
sterben
zu ihnen gehörte lord mountbatten ein
cousin der queen s sieht die königin
nicht davon ab den friedensprozess zu
unterstützen 2012 reichte sie dem
ehemaligen ira kommandanten martin
mcguinness die hand eine große geste der
versöhnung
im museum in derry dagegen wirkte
konflikt unsterblich wurde ist mitglied
im orden der prentice boys einer 200
jahre alten protestantischen
bruderschaft deren motto niemals
aufgeben
damals waren wir auf dem höhepunkt der
troubles in nordirland und alle jungen
leute in meiner gruppe
ich war damals 16 und betraten
irgendwelchen organisationen bei weil
wir natürlich das gefühl hatten dass
unser land bedroht war dass man uns in
ein vereintes irland bringen wollte wir
mussten eine organisation beitreten von
der wir glaubten dass sie die union mit
großbritannien verteidigen werde
1688 verbarrikadierten sich die
protestanten hinter den berühmten
stadtmauern von derry bis die katholiken
aufgaben das museum erzählt die
geschichte konsequent aus sicht der
protestanten 2,7 millionen euro hat die
eu dazu gezahlt das entsprechende schild
steht achtlos im keller herum
damit aber die erinnerung an den alten
hass nicht verblasst wird jedes jahr
eine nachbildung des protestantischen
general zu landen die verbrannt der zu
den katholiken übergelaufen sein soll
für die meisten protestanten aus als da
wird landi immer ein verräter bleiben
und ihr stellt jedes jahr sicher dass er
wirklich tot ist war symbolisch
verbrennen wir landen jedes jahr jedes
jahr auch veranstalten die anhänger des
königreichs viele paraden in ganz
nordirland die sie hier in randalstown
ist die erste seit corona außerdem wird
100 jahre nordirland gefeiert die freude
ist groß der druck auch die protestanten
haben mehrheitlich für den bhc rexit
gestimmt und fühlen sich jetzt doch
verraten dies ist eine gute gelegenheit
zu zeigen was man davon hält diese
märsche sind ein teil unserer geschichte
unserer kultur und unserer tradition
aber es hat jetzt auch eine neue
bedeutung weil wir so unseren widerstand
gegen die grenze in der irischen see
ausdrücken
unser british sein ich bin stolz darauf
dass wir so unseren wunsch ausdruck
verleihen ein land im vereinigten
königreich zu bleiben personifikation
von allem schönen das mit dem königreich
assoziiert wird ist natürlich die queen
die queen ist eine großartige monarchin
stadtführerinnen frau wir beten sie an
wir hätten gerne dass sie für immer lebt
überall im protestantischen nordirland
ist die krone präsent auch in der
orangerie von valery queen hängt
selbstverständlich ein porträt der queen
ist die nationalhymne wird bei jedem
unserer meetings gesungen oder nach den
band proben am ende jeder parade in
nordirland sind wir der green vermutlich
ergebener zeigen ihr mehr respekt als
jeder andere teil des vereinigten
königreichs alles was die britische
identität zu stärken scheint ist heilig
prinz familie ist in der fünften
generation aktiv im orange oder von
coltrane vom urgroßvater zum sohn
marschieren alle mit unterm juni an jack
und doch ist auch valery in jüngster
zeit erschüttert in ihrem glauben es ist
als hätten sie ein vereintes irland
durch die hintertür eingeführt
wir fühlen uns manche sagen betrogen vom
parlament in westminster
denn boris johnson hatte ja versprochen
dass es keine grenze in der irischen see
geben wird und nun gibt es sie es hat
unser selbstverständnis verletzt
wir fühlen uns als wären wir schon dabei
zugehen als drücke man uns langsam von
großbritannien weg und das ist
insbesondere für protestanten sehr
beunruhigend
waren die paraden des orange oder früher
eine demonstration der macht der
protestantischen verwaltung über die
katholiken zu haben sie zunehmend etwas
defensives wochenende für wochenende
stehen die nazis am rand und bewundern
ihre jungs die sich in uniform schmeißen
flöten und trommeln was das zeug hält um
allen zu zeigen dass sie noch da sind
sie die briten demografisch werden die
katholiken sie weit überholt haben und
eine mehrheit der iren glaubt dass es in
25 jahren ein vereintes irland geben
wird für valerie eine horror vorstellung
am ende des tages geht es der
republikanischen bewegung darum die
briten loszuwerden
sie wollen keine britische armee keine
britischen militär einrichtungen
sie wollen keine briten in nordirland
sie wollen nicht dass ich in nordirland
bin aber das ist mein zuhause das meiner
familie seit hunderten von jahren warum
ist das nicht nur meine heimat warum bin
ich plötzlich ein
wie nennen sie das noch ob migrant das
macht doch keinen sinn
[Musik]
inside armer dagegen sehen sie licht am
ende eines 100 jahre alten tunnels
damals machte sich das katholische
irland unabhängig vom protestantischen
königreich bis auf sechs provinzen heute
nordirland es entstand eine landgrenze
zur republik die man jetzt nur noch an
der plötzlich beginnenden
straßenmarkierung erkennt statt 100
jahre teilung des landes feiern sie hier
40 jahre hungerstreik 1981 hungerte sich
das ehepaar mitglied bobby sands zu tode
er kämpfte für die einheit irland
im werkraum in sitz wohl kaum auch nur
ein freund großbritanniens und keiner
der für den exit gestimmt hat einige
kämpften auch nach dem waffenstillstand
weiter sophie etwa saß für
mitgliedschaft bei der neuen ira und
waffenbesitz im gefängnis inzwischen
steht es um seine sache so gut dass er
sich ganz gelassen geben kann
der wind hat sich in den letzten fünf
jahren so richtig gewendet vor zehn
jahren hat niemand über ein vereinigtes
irland gesprochen
es wäre auch kein deutsches fernsehteam
gekommen um darüber zu reden jetzt schon
jeder spricht darüber und ich glaube es
wird passieren
es sollte passiert manchmal holland ist
24 und finanzberaterin sie arbeitet im
norden ihr freund lebt im süden viele
ihrer generation sehen dass die eu ihnen
geholfen hat so lange nordirland in der
eu war durfte ist irisch und british
gleichzeitig sein
wir sind doch gleich wir wollen alle
dasselbe aber großbritannien bietet das
eine und irland das andere
wir würden das gerne mission in einem
glücklichen land für alle wir brauchen
ein bisschen von beiden nicht alle sind
bereit sich eine eigene identität
zusammen zu stellen was mit den
protestanten passiere wenn es zu einer
vereinigung mit irland kommt frage ich
einen kenning zurück nach england
die wollen hier gar nicht sein sie
zeigen hier ihren linien jack rot weiß
blau
aber wir sind in irland der ist hier
nicht willkommen und wird es nie sein
die sollen zurück nach england
auch auf die frage nach der queen hält
ihn nichts zurück auf ob die queen ins
obama mögen wir die queen nicht absolut
nicht was die uns ja alles angetan haben
wirklich nicht wir reden hier nicht über
die queen
so fiel um versöhnliches wird man in
england dagegen kaum zu hören bekommen
hier wird die queen von den allermeisten
verehrt deutlich spürbar war das zuletzt
wieder bei der großen anteilnahme am
tode prinz philips des ehemannes der
königin identifikation mit dem
königshaus stolz auf die vergangenheit
und die eigene nation die sind themen
auf die die im land regierenden
konservativen zuletzt verstärkt gesetzt
haben
besonders im norden englands kommt das
gut an hier wurde mehrheitlich für den
bhc rexit gestimmt dabei heißen diese
gegenden im norden englands red wo die
rote wand seit jahrzehnten wurde hier
beständig die arbeiterpartei labour
gewählt von menschen wie den besuchern
des arbeitervereins von now for speed
einem stadtteil von middlesbrough nach
den lockerungen der korona beschränkung
ist das leben auf dem weg zur normalität
zurückzukehren
es wird wie der bingo gespielt später
soll es dann noch musikalische
unterhaltung geben
doch in der politik ist nichts mehr wie
es einmal war
im gegensatz zu den anderen teilen des
königreichs in denen überwiegend
linksliberal gewählt wurde haben hier
jetzt die tories das sagen und die leute
glauben den versprechungen der
konservativen lokalpolitiker dass nun
alles besser wird
der brh exit hat eine große rolle
gespielt
die leute haben für die tories gestimmt
weil sie raus aus europa wollten und
benhausen hat dieser gegend gut getan
bernhard mittels power und dem ganzen
nordosten eine menge gebracht und viele
unternehmen angezogen
er macht das gut und damit ein bisschen
nach vorne zu bringen
sie wollen die red bull einreißen und
endlich die labour hochburgen im
nordosten und yorkshire sichern und der
einfachste weg ist und mit geld um sich
zu werfen
besagter benhausen der so viele
investitionen an land gezogen hat und
auf den deshalb so laute lobeshymnen
gesungen werden ist der bürgermeister
der region ein zusammenschluss mehrere
gemeinden entlang des flusses thies
und so etwas wie der neue poster boy der
konservativen
bei den regionalwahlen im mai wurden mit
riesiger mehrheit im amt bestätigt auch
premierminister johnson dem hier im
norden auch die zahlreichen fehler bei
der pandemie bekämpfung offensichtlich
nichts anhaben können zeigt sich gerne
mit tauschen die popularität der beiden
verhafteten tores sogar bei einer
parlaments nachwahl in einem ort der
jahrzehnte lang in der hand von labour
zu einem klaren sieg
stahlwerke berg und schiffsbau waren
lange der stolz des nordostens mit den
niedergang der schwerindustrie stieg die
arbeitslosigkeit viele menschen fühlten
sich vernachlässigt und im stich
gelassen der exit und die konservativen
versprachen da einen radikalen wandel
konkret brachte aufsteiger hat schon
mehr flüge für den regionalen flughafen
und arbeitsplätze dort die er dann auch
bei einem seiner vielen twitter
auftritte anpries außerdem gelang es ihm
eine abteilung des finanzministeriums
und einen zollfreien hafen an den tiefs
zu holen
import oft mittels büro werden sogar
wieder schiffe gebaut fischtrawler
genauer gesagt nach dem gezerre um die
fischereirechte im dragset vertrag mit
der eu ein bild mit symbolcharakter
nichts scheint unmöglich erklärt uns
charline ettl vom betreiber dieser
hafenanlage in den letzten zwölf monaten
hat seine firma umgerechnet 21 millionen
euro investiert
wir haben eine neue recycling fabrik
gebaut die plastikmüll in brennstoff
kugeln um waltet die stadt kohle in
kraftwerken verwendet werden mit der
technologie sind wir hier vor ort
weltweit führend wir haben vier
millionen für ein neues hauptquartier
ausgegeben und das hafenbecken tiefer
ausgehoben um größere schiffe anzulocken
der port oft mittels büro ist teil des
bisher größten britischen freihafens der
gerade an den ufern des teams entsteht
dass mein charlie nette sorgt in jedem
fall für aufmerksamkeit und frischen
wind
zum teufel mit dem ständigen gejammer
wir alle hier
ob ich der bürgermeister oder der mann
auf der straße wir alle glauben dass nun
der nordosten dran ist und uns die
besten zeiten noch bevorstehen
wir stecken voller energie und es
herrscht großer enthusiasmus
zusammenzuarbeiten und uns
voranzubringen
es werden wie der arbeitsplätze
geschaffen im nordosten an anderer
stelle aber drohen sie verloren zu gehen
nicht jeder hier in der gegend ist
plötzlich zu einem tarif ein geworden
dieser geschäftsmann aus newcastle lässt
keinen zweifel daran was er von der
partei die in seinen augen für den
bericht verantwortlich ist hält dave
stone leitet die wahlen brauerei und an
jenem abend eine zusammenkunft
unabhängiger braumeister aus allen
teilen des landes wie so vielen anderen
unternehmen in großbritannien hat der
exit days geschäft schwer geschadet
[Musik]
seine hoffen betonten ips sind ein
verkaufsschlager
beim brauen von kraft bieren sind die
briten ganz weit vorn
zehn jahre habe er gebraucht den ruf
seiner brauerei so aufzubauen um seinen
gerstensaft auf dem kontinent
erfolgreich verkaufen zu können
seitdem bei exit ist dieser markt jedoch
für seine ja nur begrenzt haltbar waren
zusammengebrochen
welchen mist reibungsloser handel was
für eine großartige lüge das war ich
denke all diese negativen folgen liegen
noch verborgen hinter den folgen der
pandemie wenn wir nicht durch diese
verrückten zeiten gehen müssten wäre der
brh exit noch viel mehr in den
schlagzeilen und den exit befürwortern
kommt das sehr gelegen
es ist sicher noch möglich unser bier an
jemanden in berlin zu verkaufen
aber ich habe keine ahnung wie lange es
dauert es da hinzubekommen und warum
sollten die guten bier trinkenden
menschen aus deutschland mein bier
kaufen wenn der transport ewig dauert
und andere europäische länder ebenso
gutes bier brauen die wir hier im
vereinigten königreich
da müssen die engländer ihr bier jetzt
eben mehr oder weniger alleine trinken
das einst stolze königreich droht zu
einem mittel england zu schrumpfen
im englischen nationalismus so klagen
viele lagen die wurzeln des brh exit
denn nun das königreich zu zerreißen
droht
hinzu kommt frust über die verschiebung
des freedom day der premier hatte
versprochen im juni alle corona
beschränkungen aufzuheben
die data variante für den briten vor
augen dass die pandemie längst nicht
überwunden ist
im reich der queen gärt es wie lange
bleibt das königreich noch vereint wie
kann es den loslösung sehnsüchten seiner
einzelner nationen widerstehen die queen
allein kann den laden nicht
zusammenhalten
[Musik]